ポケットモンスター縮めて本家もこの世界には不振が生き物が満ち溢れておるのじゃ
なんか実際はをランポケ峯が実際にオランダ下傷を受けと命令ないひとつのために
ポケモンカードという遊びがあるのじゃあポケモンカードは名前の通りポケモン王
カードでしたものじゃあ訳してボケかと言われており
ぞ今の人間はポケモンがいない悲しみをポケモンのゲームやおけがで大きなって俺の
じゃ
ま実際ポケモンなっていたら怖くてた花がの今日も元気に
ぴ pikachu はいというわけではーキド博士じゃよろしくお願いします僕の
周りの人今密着ジャポケカが流行ってるんで僕も結構やってましてもうみてください
この数
こんな日高を山雨やばい本なんかも全部ポッケかだしこんなかも全部こんなかも全部
だしなんだかなんかここらへんも全部わけじゃないですね母がをながらはし一番カード
を持ってもかもしれないよねだからポケかかってれば誰を買ってると思うんですよそこ
で今回この大量がポケモンカードを生かしテント用仕掛けてみたいと思う
やることは簡単だ今は
私のまでに居るや皿はみんなのけがが大好き茶舗結果を見るだけで興奮して逝って
しまう者も居るず
それは言い過ぎたが普通の人間じゃさはならんが私のバルブ人間はみんなおけがが
大好き者というわけで今日は家の前に車を置いておこうと思うのだがその車をもボディ
周り全部ポケモンをカードにしてしまおうという企画者
ただでさえポケモンを数えてほっくんしてしまう人が ok 方だけの車を見てしまう
と思う
おうっ
ダウンぜをダウンされてしまうもちろん口径化だけど車雲楽しみだがそれを見たポケが
プレイヤーはどんな反応するのかもと思ってをたまず海猿聞いて早速上州の力を借り
ながらフルの大木かでいっぱいにしていこうと大空ぴっぴかちゅうおう吹け部を
バッターの将軍私じゃあーけどじゃんというわけ
早速車に本脚を張っているわけなんだからまあ直せず
中にガムテープを貼るとカーン後か予報でてしまうそんなことをポケモンませのみんな
やってはいけないぞて全てのポケモンカードにスリーブ入れさせていただいて居るこれ
で直接カードが汚れることはないのじゃ
これだけで今ゴミどもが頑張っておりだ雑食は
下バッチコリと応力していこうと思うぞ i 領土というもんカードざっ
[音楽]
ポケモンカードだけど母訳してい
ポッキーカーじゃ
8個の重役聖者の音響をつけて帰るんじゃん大外もんゲットじゃろう
ラッシュで逃げてきよったろー
リボンさあ女今日は計付の元カノの卒業好きじゃぞ
みんなポケモンゲットぞ
少ない構え gv 8倍もあるしたばいばーいやばい我サバイバル
グレープが消えてしまったぞ
denham
はぁ
car
想像の5億倍大変じゃのう
氏ねよええ
いっ
大変じゃあ以前名ほどポケモンカードスリーブに入れて準備していたのじゃ
カードは足りなくなってしまった
やっとないのが終わったの者像
いやもう本当に大変でしたよ再度割るだけでだいたい1時間半ぐらいかかっております
裏面もほぼ完成じゃ
ただナンバーが隠れているのでもう運転はできないの者像れ何がめんどいてスリーブに
出て作業がまじでメンドクセに何かカードを着続けるわけにはいかん
ないのじゃポケモンマスターとしてのフィギュアフロントの部分に貼って行こう
[音楽]
me
wh
全国のポケモントレーナーの削ぐ体表安定しました
約2時間をかけて馬を結果にすることが
べき様のだぞ
goo
大外もんトレーダーの将軍どうじゃプロントあもうねんか
一応車のベースは残しておくことでラースとかナンバー格下からも走れねーけど
エンブレムはまっきょになっておるぞ
素敵じゃ脳圧はもう全部ポケモンカードゲームだった完奈己
コーヒー風呂もポケモンカード使用者が再度も見るか
義理も全部子疑問カード仕様になっておく増
牛風もいい感じに行ったけども心辺が諦めてしまった
ユーロしてくれんかのぉおおお
というわけでも新車がぞこんなのにがってたら後期もマスターはどんな感じ
どんな声を出すのか早速試したいと思うぞ嘘
受け持ってる
エイ
まいちばーん
マルチ規定廃止ってや描いいやマジ邪魔じゃねえっ
なんかめっちゃやばいめっちゃうまいメンツや別
麻雀アクセスとしたした車
やばいやばい
アブジャん
[音楽]
開く
無理ある仕事を振っ
いたずらがされたテーママークが入る
いたずらがされておったぞいるんだけど
同座
すんのこれ
[音楽]
ええええええ
ただ知恵を出されなぁ
やばいはいはこちらもいますでホンダいやいやいやー
ガチでヤバイって本当に何がやばい本当に甘え度がやばいヤードに親6台と絵本といっ
た
にもやばくないですかね
イヤッハー
ハイアールええええ
[音楽]
me
teame
anaru
me
aa 分
亡き母ゼノン
mature じゃあみんなそこに反応するんだろうサイドも見てみられます
どう者を聞かんじゃああー
どこぞ
[音楽]
ch